[موسيقى]
معجزات على قلتها تنبثق من اعماق الكارثه
قصص لجينه في صمودهم تحدوا الطبيعه دون
ماء وطعام لاكثر من 190 ساعه قصص اثلجت
قلوب عائلات لم تمل للانتظار رغم قله
الامال واطفال اعادوا من العتمه وفي
اذهانهم نكهات طفوله عالقه بالوانها لكن
فرحه العوده الى الحياه لم تنسم ملايين
المشردين في سوريا وتركيا حقيقه فقدانهم
لكل شيء اشخاص وممتلكات ولم يبقى بين
ايديهم غير الذكريات فهؤلاء اصبحت احلامهم
مؤجله لاجل غير مسمى
[موسيقى]
انا نازح مغيب من اربع سنوات
فجاه اجا صار زلزال الساعه ثلاثه ونصف
اربعه بالضبط ما بعرف
نهدد البناي انجرح واحد من عندي من
الاولاد
الجرحى معبينا الشوارع الشهداء المشافئ
تعبت دمارك كتير بنايات لبينا نداء انه في
مخيم ايواء لانه اخواننا المضرين كثيرين
وعم نعمل بقدر الله عليه وسبحان الله انه
الجو برد مع كل هالبرد لبينا نداء
واخواننا انا نازح بحس بموعات راح بيته
اللي عنده ماوى يعني لله الامر الحمد لله
وين هلا عم نسمع يعني نداء الصغار عم نلبي
اخواتنا ان شاء الله وبتمنى من كل واحد
يعني قادر على العمل يعني يذهب بشكل تطوعي
ويساعد اخواتنا
حجاره متراكمه شكلت كوابيسها متلاحقه
لسبعه ايام لكنها اسوار اخفت وراءها مخاوف
اكبر تتمثل بطبيعه الخطوه التاليه
السوريون واتراك واظبوا على انتظار مؤلم
رغم فقدان الامل واخرون بداوا لملمه ماسي
الكارثه والخروج من مرحله الانكار لا
منازل لا اعمال لا مقتنياتنا والاقصى
افراد عائله اقل
معظم مجري ما كانوا عملي كل شيء دمر صحوه
من هول الفاجعه اثارت مخاوف مئات الالاف
من التجمد بردا في العراء درجات حراره
شديده الانخفاض لا ترضعها خيم قماشيه او
ثياب خفيفه كما لا تحمي اطفالا من نزله
برد مسكنه الجو بارد وسنتجمد هنا حتى
الموت اذا جلسنا داخل الخيمه فسوف نتجمد
ياتي ذلك وسط تحذيره متزايده من كارثه
ثانيه اكثر ضررا من سابقتها تنبع من تاخر
وصول فرق الطوارئ والمساعدات لملايين
المشردين فالالاف ينامون في سياراتهم قرب
الانقاض
كانوا في العراء بظروف متدهوره ومروعه مع
صعوبه كبيره في الوصول للوقود والمياه
والكهرباء وامدادات الاتصالات
منازل مؤقته او فنادق خطه الحكومه التركيه
لواء الاشخاص الذين دمرت منازلهم او من
يخافون العوده لابنيه صامده بشقوقها
ومهدده بالسقوط
فالرئيس التركي تعهد بعدم السماح ببقاء
المواطنين في الشارع واعاده بناء مئات
الالاف من المباني بسرعه وان كانت تعهدات
بعيده المنال على حد وصف الكثيرين لكن حتى
هكذا وعوده لم تدس عتبه السوريين اكثر من
خمسه ملايين شخص يضافون الى اعداد مماثله
بعثرتهم الحرب خلال السنوات الاثنتي عشره
الماضيه هؤلاء سيتشاركون نقص المعونات
وظروف السكن الصعبه وبروده الطقس
وفي وقت يتواصل تمشيط اكوام الانقاذ
الشاهقه بحثا عن نفس او صوت يطفئ قلوبنا
ترتجف حسره وبردا يفضل ناجون العوده
لمنازلهم المتضرره بشكل بالغ لحفظ كرامه
اب لا يريد لاطفاله امراضا او امراه
انهكها موت معيل
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان انه من المهم جدا تامين وصول
المساعدات الى المستحقيها في مناطق تركيا
ومناطق سوريا كافه
الكارثه التي حلت بكل من تركيا وسوريا
كبيره جدا وتقتضي توفير المساعدات
المناسبه المملكه ردت على الكارثه من خلال
ارسال المساعدات وفرق الاغاثه الى كلا
البلدين ونشجع الجميع على تقديم المساعدات
وفق ما تم بحثه في الاجتماع الثنائي مع
المندوب السامي السيد مرعب ومن المهم جدا
تامين وصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها في
تركيا وسوريا كافه يجب العمل على تخفيف
معاناه الشعب السوري ونبذر ما بوسعنا من
اجل وصول المساعدات الى المناطق كافه في
الداخل السوري
قال ياسر طرافه منسق الاستجابه الطارئه في
الجمعيات الدوليه لرعايه الكوارث والذي
يعمل في مخيم الاغاثه السعودي في جنديرس
بشمال غرب سوريا قال ان عمليه توزيع
المساعدات السعوديه التي وصلت من مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه في جنديرس بدات طبعا
بدايه بحب اذكر انه اول شيء هذه الطائرات
دخلت من خلال معبر جوي اغاثه بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبين تركيا طبعا هذه
الطائرات دخل منها الى سوريا قافله واحده
اللي هي عباره كانت 11 شحنه بقيه الحملات
يتم توزيعها بين سوريا وبتركيا بالنسبه
للجانب السوري فاللي دخل هو عباره عن 11
شاحنه من خلال معبر الحمام مع تركيا هاي
الشواحين تتضمن عده مواد اللي هي مواد
غذائيه خلال غذائيه ومواد غير غذائيه اللي
هي طبعا كانت عباره عن خيم وسلال ايواء
واغطيه
للناس اللي ضررت ياثر الزلزال اللي صار
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا طبعا هاي المواد
التي تم توزيعها بمناطق ادلب ومناطق عفرين
احنا متواجدين به وسط من ناحيه جنديرس عم
نقوم ببناء واحد المخيمات طبعا هذا المخيم
رقم ثلاثه اللي احنا عم نباشر فيه ان شاء
الله وغدا الفرق راح تكون متواجده بمناطق
ادلب لا ان شاء الله رب العالمين حنحاول
نوصل لاكبر عدد ممكن من الناس اللي ضررت
خلال الفتره القادمه
الخيام ولكن التجهيزات هنا تخوننا دائما
التجهيزات الانترنت صعوبه التواصل تخوننا
دائما في الدخول بين الاهالي ولكن في
النشرات القادمه سندخل بين الاهالي
سنستضيفهم طبعا كما تلاحظون على شاشه
الكاميرا هناك العديد من العوائل التي اتت
الى هنا تنتظر الانتهاء من بناء هذه
الخيام لكي يستلموها لكي يؤمنوا انفسهم
بعد ايام عصيبه مرت عليهم في ظل موجات
البرد الشديده التي تضرب المنطقه ليل
الامس يعني صراحه كانت درجه الحراره هنا
ناقص درجتان اغلب هؤلاء الاهالي كانوا
يبيتون في مراكز الايواء المؤقته منهم من
كان يبيت امام منزله المدمر بشكل جزئي
يخاف دخوله نتيجه يعني وجود هزات ارتداديه
تحدث بين الحين والاخر
من غازي عنتاب ينضم الي مفرد العربي عدد
المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن اهلا بك معنا
الاوضاع لديك الان في غازي عنتاب وبالنسبه
للاحياء الاكثر تضررا كيف كانت الاوضاع
فيها اليوم خلال ساعات النهار
فاصله تسعه على مقياس رختر ضربت مدينه
كهرمان مرعش جنوبي تركيا اذا هزتين
متزاملتين في كهرمان مرعش حدثت بحسب مركز
الابحاث التركي باربعه فاصله تسعه
بالاضافه الى الهزه التي شعرت بها هنا قبل
اقل من
هذه الهزاز ما هي رده فعل الناس يعني هل
الخوف ما زال مسيطرا عليهم بعد هذا
الزلزال المدمر وخاصه الناس التي يعني
خرجت من بيوتها ولم تعد وهي في مراكز
ايواء وحتى يعني البعض منهم في العراء
هنالك الطرفين يتعامل بطريقتين مختلفتين
ميسون مع هذه الهزات الارتداديه التي تم
تسجيلها بعد الهزه الكبيره قبل تسعه ايام
من الان
الطرف الاول هو الذي شعر بصدمه كبيره جدا
وهو خائف جدا من هذه الهزات الارتداديه
ففضل البقاء خارج المنازل خارج المباني
والابراج في اما في السيارات اما في
مخيمات اللواء وحتى البعض الاخر خرج من
المدينه من المدن الجنوبيه التركيه واتجه
الى انقره واسطنبول او مدن حتى الشمال
التركي او حتى في القرى التي لديهم فيها
منازل ومزارع بحسب ما تحدثت مع مواطنين
اتراك الطرف الاخر يتعامل معها بشكل طبيعي
يقولها بان
الهزه الكبرى حدثت فبالتالي هذه الهزات
الارتداديه الطبيعيه كما تحدثت مع شخص
تركي قبل قال بان قال
بصريح العباره لا تقلق الامر طبيعي جدا
والهزات هذه تحدث باستمرار ونحن متعودون
عليها حتى قبل هذه هذا الزلزال الكبير
ولكن هذا الزلزال الذي وقع قبل ثمانيه
ايام بقياسات كبيره جدا لكن بشكل عام
طبيعي
هل تشعر بان هنا يعني السكان خرجوا منها
بشكل كبير كيف هي الحركه هناك محل تجاريه
موضوع الغاز الذي ايضا تاثر بفضل بجراء
هذا الزلزال موضوع الكهرباء كيف يمكن ان
تصف لنا الوضع مشاهداتك خلال النهار يعني
كيف هي غازي عنتاب كيف تبدو بعد هذا
الزلزال
في الحقيقه الوقت متاخر الان لذلك اغلب
المحل مغلقه ولكن في النهار عندما كنا
نتجول في انحاء المدينه ابرز المشاهدات
المباني اغلبها مغلقه المحل المحل اغلبها
مغلق الى بعض المحاله البسيطه جدا التي
قررت الافتتاح في محل بسيطه تحدث عن مطعم
من بين عدد كبير من محاله يتواجد في طابور
طويل جدا من الاشخاص الذين لم يجدوا اماكن
اخرى لشراء الاكل بالاضافه الى ان محل
مواد التموينيه فاتحه الا بجوز قليل جدا
يعني في كل منطقه تجد مكان واحد فقط
تستطيع ابتلاع منه
الاغراض بالاضافه الى بعض المناطق الاخرى
التي
لا زالت مغلقه بشكل كبير وتحدثت ايضا مع
اتراقلوا بان هذا هو توجيه من السلط هنا
من سلطات المدينه والولايه التي قالت بانه
بعض المباني لا تستطيع ان تعود من جديد
بشكل طبيعي نظرا لخطوره هذه المباني
الخطوره القائمه على هذه المباني
هزات الارتداديه او حتى
نعم اما الهزات الارتداديه او قياس مدى
سلامه هذا المبنى بعد الزلزال الذي حدث
قبل تسعه ايام بالاضافه الى ذلك
الكهرباء عادت بشكل شبه طبيعي الانترنت
والشبكات الاتصال عادت بشكل شبه طبيعي الا
من الغاز وخطوط امداد الغاز التي تاثرت
خطوط الامداد التي تصل الى المدينه
الصناعيه غازي عنتاب تاثرت بسبب هذا
الزلزال ولا تزال اجزاء كبيره من المدينه
لا يتواجد فيها الماء الدافئ جراء عدم
تواجد هذا الغاز كل المياه بارده في
المنطقه في ظل درجات حراره متدنيه جدا
ميسون شكرا لك عبد المحسن الحربي مفرد
العربي كنت معي من غازي عنتاب يعطيكم الف
عافيه
خيام تنصب من جديد مشهد يشبه بدايات
التغريبه السوريه
بعد ان اعتقدوا انهم استقروا في ملاجئهم
ان كانت مساكن او مخيمات هجرتهم الارض مره
اخرى
هنا ريف ادلب هي ذاتها الارض التي اهتزت
قبل اكثر من اسبوع تحت قاطينها لتدمر ما
بقي من منازل بكل قسوتها تستقبل الذين
نزحوا مرتين او ربما اكثر
بعضهم وصفوا الكارثه التي ضربتهم بالرعب
الذي يفوق الرعب الحرب صار عمري 36 سنه
اكلنا طيران وغزاير وبرابيل وما خفنا مثل
هالخوفها بتاريخ حياته صار ما شفت اكبر من
هالرعبه هاي
هذه ارضيه قويه والله
علي وما حسيت غير تحت الدردين
بالضبط يعني
عاداتهم شحيحه وطرقات مغلقه واجراءات
مطوله كلما تاخرت كلما زادت معاناه نازح
الزلزال
ليكونوا الضحيه وهم فرق واغاثه النفس في
الوقت ذاته
[موسيقى]
والدمار اللي صاروا بها البيوت
بعض من المنظمات المحليه تحاول بما تملك
من امكانيات بسيطه ان تمد يد العون سواء
بتامين الخيام والقليل من القوه البشريه
العامله او بمعونه بسيطه
قامت منظمه
المراكز الهواء في مناطق ارمناز ومعرض
مصرين وجنديرس بالاضافه الى الاتارب
والتوامه وحارم
نزوح او لجوء لعله قدر لا مهرب منه امام
شعب قضاء اخر عقد في التنقل واللجوء الى
اي مامن او ما ظنوا انه المامن الا ان
الارض نفسها لم تعد تحتمل معاناتهم
اذا عمر العربيه
من الرياضه ينظم اليها من اسعد عواد
الزعبي عميد اهلا بكم معنا اليوم الجدل
قائم بخصوص المساعدات الانباء تتحدث بانه
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا ترفض اي مساعدات
قادمه من النظام وبالتالي ايضا ليس هناك
من يؤكد بانه النظام حقيقه يقوم بارسال
مساعدات الى هذه المناطق اين الحقيقه ماذا
يجري
مساء الخير
عندما تقول هل فعلا هناك لدى نظام جديه في
ارسال المساعدات اقول لك لم ولن يكن لدى
النظام اي جديه في ارسال مساعدات النظام
يكفي ان نقول انه في البدايات او في اليوم
الاول والثاني والثالث عندما كانت العالم
في يعني في في الازمه او كما يقال فيه
يعني في اوجه الحاجه الى المساعدات نتحدث
منها عن الزلزال لا نعود الى
الخلفيه يعني حزينه بكل ما تعني هذه
الكلمه لكن حتى في اليوم الثاني للزلزال
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه النظام ومستشاره
بشار الاسد بثينه شعبان يقولها بالحرف
ولوسال الاعلام جهرا وليس يعني سرا قالوا
نحن لن نبعث مساعدات لانها ستكون بيد
الارهابين وطبعا يقصدون ان 6 ملايين سوري
موجودين في شمال غربي سوريا هم ارهابين
هكذا يعتبرونهم وبالتالي يعني يعطيها او
يتحدث بها صراحه انه لن يبعث مساعدات هذا
اولا
اسعد يعني هل من الممكن ان تكون الدول
مثلا ضغطت على النظام لان يقبل بارسال
المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا
الدول ضغطت ودليل ان مكتب الامم المتحده
اول امس قال انا لن ادخل او لن ادخل
المساعدات بالتعاون او بالتنسيق او بشكل
مشترك مع يعني منظمه الهلال الاحمر السوري
باعتبار انها 99% من هؤلاء العناصر هم
متابعين المخابرات العسكريه او المخابرات
الجويه لان المنظمه مكتب منظمه تماما
حقيقه هذا هذه المنظمه منظمه الهلال
الاحمر التي كانت خلال الفترات الحرب تقوم
بدور جدا يعني تقوم بتصوير اماكن الفصائل
وترسل احداثياتها لطيران النظام وكذلك
ايضا كانت تدخل عبوات اثناء دخول الاتجاه
المناطق اذا هو ليس له ثقه بهذه المنظمه
وبالتالي ايضا حتى الجيش الحر او الشعب
السوري الذي النازح في المناطق الشماليه
ليس له اي ثقه يعلم تماما ان هؤلاء هم
عناصر المخابرات الجويه وهم مصدر اذى
ويعني بالنسبه للسوريين برايك شمال غرب
سوريا يعني يرفض اخذ هذه
خوفا من ان تدخل عليهم مثلا هذه المنظمات
وبالتالي يعني هم يخافون من وجودهم بينهم
لا يوجد يعني لم تقدم لهم مساعدات حتى
يرفض لم يقدم النظام له يا اختي الكريمه
النظام يعني منذ منذ عام 2011 المساعدات
التي تدخل اليه كان يقوم بثلاث اعمال او
ثلاثه اجراءات ونحن تحدثنا مع المتحده
بكثير من المره تحدث معهم وانا كنت في
الاردن اربع سنوات اتحدث معهم بكل شحنه
يعني مشاهدات تدخل الداخل نقول اولا
النظام كان يبدلها ويعطي يعني المواد
الفاسده التي لا تصلح البشري البشري او
احيانا يعني يقوم بتبديله بشكل كامل بمعنى
يعني ادخلنا على سبيل المثال فرضا الى
المنطقه الزبدان عندما كانت محاصره ادخلنا
اليهم البس الشتويه وكذلك ادخلنا اليهم
معلبات اقامه النظام يعني بمصادره كل هذه
المواد وادخل اليهم يعني اسطوانات مياه هل
زبدان ابن دان منطقه المياه تحتاج الى
مياه يعني انظر الى هذا هذا الاستهتار من
قبل النظام بالمنظمه الدوليه المتحده على
ذلك طبعا كثير مثال لكن انا هل قدم النظام
في الفتره الحاليه اي مساعده النظام لم
يقدم حتى مساعدات للمتضررين داخل المناطق
النظام هو يقوم بتسليمها الى الميليشيات
الطائفيه الايرانيه بالسيده زينب او بتدمر
او حتى في مناطق حلب لماذا اذا يعني هل
قدم نظام عندما يقدم نظام ويصور انه يقدم
نظام حقيقه
للشمال الغربي سوريا نقول والله قدم لكن
لم يقدم ولن يقدم
بعدم ضغط الدولي بالنسبه لمناطق شمال غرب
سوريا هي متضرره تعيش ماساه حقيقيه هي
بحاجه لكل انواع المساعدات من خلال تقييمك
لهذه الايام الثمانيه هل من يديرون هذه
المناطق حتى الان
يقومون بالعمل الصحيح هل يقومون بتقديم
المساعدات بشكل جيد الى الناس هل يتخذون
الاجراءات هل ايضا
يتحدثون مع الخارج حتى تصل هذه المساعدات
الى حقها ام هناك تقصير تمام انت تعلمين
والجميع يعلم ان الامم المتحده ما زالت
تتشاور فيما بينها خلال العامين او ثلاث
عوامل السابقه اين المعبر الذي يسمح بدخول
المساعدات من خلاله روسيا ترفض وتضع
النظام وعندما ادخلت احدى القوافل عام
2019 قام الطيران الروسي بقصف هذه القافله
ودمرها عن بك ابيع حوالي بحدود الاربعين
شاحنه تحمل مساعدات انسانيه وغذائيه للناس
الجائعين اذا دروس سترفض والنظام كذلك
ايضا يرفض تماما ادخال اي مساعدات لكن
عندما نتحدث عن دور الداخل في المناطق
الغربيه شمال الغربي سوريا نقول هؤلاء
عملوا عملا جبارا بسبب عدم توفر
الامكانيات خاصه فيما يتعلق بامكانيات رفع
الانقاذ يعني والوصول الى
المفقودين داخل نتحدث عن الدفاع المدني
والخوذ البيضاء لانه حقيقه يعني بعمل جبار
ولكن نحن نتحدث عن من يدير يعني الحكومه
المؤقته بعض المس ببعض الفصائل
الفصائل بما بما تملك لديها من ادوات ومن
وسائل يعني دعم سواء بخيم سواء بمواد
غذائيه لم تقصر اطلاقا بالعكس كان هناك
سباق ما بين اقاله الوصل وانا اتواصل معهم
يوميا بالمناسبه واعلم ماذا قدم واذا
اردتم ان ارسل اليكم جداول بما قدموه فانا
جاهز يعني انا اعلم تماما السباق بينهم من
اجل الحصول على مساعدات او تقديمها الى
اهلنا في الداخل لكن عندما نتحدث عن
الحكومه المؤقته الحكومه لا تملك الا
المشاهدات التي يرسل المجتمع الدولي الذي
لم يرسل الى الان يعني المجتمع الدولي الى
الان ما زال في طور الحوار والمناقشات في
مجلس الامن ريثما يتخذ القرار هناك كانت
شاحنات موجوده على معبر باب الهوات تابع
لمكتب المتحده للاسف الشديد لم تدخل بحجه
ان هناك معبر مغلق وهذا غير صحيح او طريق
غير جاهز وهذا ايضا غير صحيح لديهم اليه
يعني بدات تحل امورها يعني بدات بعض
الشاحنات تدخل الى الداخل السوري ونامل ان
تبقى الامور كذلك
اشكرك من الرياض العميد اسعد عوض الزعبي
لنغضب مشاعر تختلط بالبرد والفقد والدموع
السوريون حملوا مجددا اكياس الجثث التي
اعتادوا حملها لسنوات بعضهم حظي باقامه
طقوس وداعا وان كانت مختصره والبعض الاخر
لا يزال بمرحله انتظار خروجهم من تحت
الانقاض
الحرقه لم تزل ببدايتها لكن الغضب عارم لم
يعتادوا البقاء في الصف الخلفي رغم اهمال
اوضاعهم لسنوات فصرخاتهم ليست لغطاء او
طعام رغم ضاله المساعدات التي وصلت الى
الشمال غرب سوريا وانعدامها ببعض المناطق
اجل نريد ناكل التراب بس انحفظ كرامتنا
السوريون يصفونه بالتخلي والنسيانه مع
التماسهم لفروق كثيره في التعامل المحلي
والدولي مع جيرانهم الاتراك شركائهم
بالكارثه والدمار الكارثه لم تقدر حدودا
لكن الجدار بينهما حدد وحدد خدمات كثيره
من الانقاذ للاسعاف للماوى
فعلى الجهه الاخرى من الجدار الاف عمال
الانقاذ والالاف من المسعفين اضافه الى
معدات رفع ثقيله وجرافات وكلاب بوليسيه
تجب الشوارع صخب محركات ضغط عليه احيانا
صافره سيارات الاسعاف وزحام المساعدات لكن
في الجهه السوريه وقفت عمليات الانقاذ منذ
يومين صمت مستغرب تحتمه امكانات محدوده مع
تفوق الكارثه على قدرات الخوض البيضاء
نقاط التفتيش احبطت جهود الاغاثه الدوليه
والمساعده العاجله في الجزء الذي تسيطر
عليه الفصائل المدعومه من تركيا
والمساعدات المنتظره تعرقل دخولها لاكثر
من منطقه بسبب تقسيمات جغرافيه وانقسامات
سياسيه وولائيه
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن رامي اهلا
بك معنا مال جديد لديكم بخصوص
الاحصائيات اخر الحصيله بالنسبه للمفقودين
بالنسبه للقتله وايضا عدد الناجين حتى
الان
نعم بالنسبه مساء الخير بالنسبه
للاحصائيات هي عليه التغيير فيها اكثر من
5000 و300 هناك المفقودين نحو 2000 مفقود
ولكن المفقود ليس شرطا ان يكون تحت
الانقاذ اعتقد بان حتى موضوع تحت الانقاذ
لا اعتقد بان كل شيء انتهى لان هناك يعني
على سبيل المثال منطقه مثل جنديرس عندما
نقول فيها 84 مبنى مهدم بشكل كامل بعد ذلك
نقول بحثنا داخل 14 مبنى والى الان يوجد
مفقودين ايضا مناطق النظام انهت فرق
الانقاذ عملها في حلب والساحل السوري طيب
هناك امنيه تهدمت هل من المعقول النصاب
يعلم بان هناك احد تحت هذه المباني التي
انهارت بشكل كامل اعتقد الامر سوف يحتاج
الى وقت يعني نعلم انهم المفقودين وتجرح
احصائيات دقيقه لنعلم اين هم اكثر من 2000
شخص على الاقل مفقودين في مناطق السيطره
المختلفه داخل التراب بالنسبه لي عدد
الناجين من من هذه الكارثه ما بين مناطق
النظام وما بين مناطق الحكومات الحكومه
المؤقته وحكومه الانقاذ الرقم يعني
خمسه ملايين ولكن اعتقد هذا الرقم مبالغ
فيه قليلا قد يكون عدد يصل الى نحو مليون
ونصف
لم تضرب
الزلزال خمسه ملايين شخص بالمناطق التي
ضربها نحو مليون ونصف شخص نعم ناجي من
الزلزال يحتاجون لمساعدات مستمره ومساعدات
عاجله
بخصوص بخصوص عدد القتلى حتى الان اذا ما
قارنا بين تركيا وسوريا طبعا يعني تركيا
اكبر وعدد السكان فيها اكبر ولكن هناك فرق
جدا شاسع هل برايك لعدم وجود جهه معينه
تقوم بهذه الاحصائيه لذلك لا نجد رقما
دقيقا حتى الان في سوريا
نتحدث على يعني بشيء مختصر في مناطق سيطره
النظام اعيد واكرر هناك الاهالي دفنوا
جثامين الذين توفوا في نتيجه زلزال في عده
بلدات وقرى في ريف ادلب الشرقي وريف حلب
الجنوبي ايضا في ريف هناك كره تم دفن
الجسامين فيها من قبل الاهالي لم تصل
اليها لا فرق طبيه لا فرق الدفاع المدني
ولا احد وصل اليها يعني الدفاع المدني
تحدث عن الاحصائيات الذين انتشلهم وبعض
الطبيه تحدثت عن احصائيات البعض حكومه
الانقاذ وزاره الصحه في عقوبه الانقاش
تحدثت عن رقم اكثر بالف رقم الدفاع المدني
يعني هناك تضارب بالارقام نحن ما نتمكن من
احصائيه يعني في جنديرس يقولون بان هناك
530 اذا كان لدينا نحن اسماء ما بين الكرد
ابناء جنديرس وما بين المهجرين عليها
الرقم وصل اكثر الى اكثر من 780 هناك يعني
يجب ان نهدا قليلا بعد ذلك تتبين الارقام
الحقيقيه
ارقام الحقيقيه هي اكبر من هذه الارقام
اليوم الامم المتحده تحدثت عن ثمانيه الاف
وخمسمائه في مناطق النظام ومناطق حكمتي
الانقاذ والحكومه المؤقته طب بالنسبه
للمساعدات رامي ماذا لديك من معلومات حول
المساعدات ان كان التي دخلت الى مناطق
النظام او التي دخلت الى شمال غرب سوريا
المناطق النظام يعني دخلت وتدخل المساعدات
دخلت من الاردن قبل قليل مساعدات اليوم
وصلت خمسه طائرات من عده الدول العربيه
النظام يعني يقول بان المساعده اتصل نعمات
كبيره من العراق نحو يعني ما بين الطائرات
التي وصلت
الى مطاع المطارات السوريه هناك 86 طائره
وصلت كل المساعدات في ابناء الشعب السوري
في هذه المنطقه الى الان من هذه المساعدات
لم يدخل اي شيء الى منطقه شرق يعني منطقه
عفوا ادلب التي تسيطر عليها التحديث
الشامي يقال بان الهيئه وهنا يجب ان يصدر
من الهيئه الهلال الاحمر السوري كنت على
احد الفضائيات مع رئيس الهلال الاحمر
السوري قال نحن اذا انت تضمن على اساس انه
انا دوله يعني اذا انت تدمن ان لا يتعرض
الينا احد سوف نقوم بادخال قافله مساعدات
الى ادلب يعني اعتقد بان هناك تركيا هي
الضامن لدخول المساعدات بنسيابيه لتلك
المنطقه اذ كان هناك جديه من النظام مثلما
وعد الجهات الدوليه بدخولها في المساعدات
ايضا اليوم دخلت مساعدات عشائريه سميها ما
شئتي بالمناطق شمال شرق سوريا مناطق
الاداره الذاتيه ومساعدات اهليه 129
الشاحنه سمح لها بالدخول من قبل عبد
الرحمن مصطفى الى مناطق سيطره الحكومه
المؤقته وهنا يعني انا كان
العقيد اسعد الزعبي او العميد يقول الجهات
الفصائل المقاتل ان تعمل هي لن تعمل هي
عملا في اليوم ولكن للضمير هيئه تحرير
الشام بكل فرقها واليتها شاركت بشكل كبير
جدا بعمليات الانطاق وهذا يعني الانسان
يتحدث بضميره كان لها دور كبير جدا
بالمشاركه بعمليات الانقاذ في ادلب وفي
جنديرس طب
المساعدات التي يعني اليوم بعض المعابر تم
فتحها يعني تحدثنا مع زميلنا جماعه عكاش
اخبرنا بان بعض المعابر تم فتحها ايضا من
معبر باب الهوى ايضا كان معنا ضيوف منه من
هناك وقالوا بانه بعض الشاحنات تدخل وانما
هل هناك من ينسق بالداخل السوريه حتى تصل
هذه المساعدات الى الناس الاكثر تضررا
اقله الناس الموجودين في العراء لانه هناك
ناس موجودين في مراكز ايواء هناك ناس
موجودين في العراق
تماما تماما الاولويه الان الاولويه الان
للناس الموجودين في العراق حسب المشاهدات
بان الذين هم تحت شجره الزيتون او تحت
الشجر يتم اعطائهم مساعدات الذين هم في
مراكز الايواء يجري تسجيل اسمائهم بعض
يعني الاشخاص قال يعني لم تصل الى
المساعدات هم يعطونا الناس تحت الاشجار
قلت له يا اخي يعني الناس تحت الاشجارهم
لديهم اولويه بعد ذلك توزع المساعدات ان
لم توزع المساعدات حينها نقوم بحملها على
المنصبات التي استلمت هذه المساعدات الامر
يعني هناك ارباح حتى في المناظرات حقيقه
الامر هناك يعني منظمات كثيره تريد ان
تستلم هذه المساعدات وتوسعها على مستحقيها
لكن يجب ان يكون هناك اثبات لدى هذه
المنظمات بانه فعلا هذا الشخص تضرر من
الزلزال ليس فقط الحصول على هذه المساعدات
دون تاكيد شكرا لك من كوفنتوس مدير المركز
السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن
بخوف وحذر تهافت رجال الانقاذ لانتشاله
ليستقبلهم هو بضحكاته البريئه انه رضيع
الانقاض الضاحك ابن الستين يوما صمد امام
الزلزال المدمر وبقي تحت الركام لخمسه
ايام في انطاكيا التركيه وحين خرج للنور
تغلبت براءته على معاناته وضحك الرضيع
الضاحك شغل الجميع منذ لحظه نقله الى
المستشفى في مدينه اضنه التركيه بقي
الصغير تحت الانقاض لمده خمسه ايام ثم نقل
الى المستشفى بواسطه الاسعاف الجويه لكن
حالته العامه جيده فهو بخير الطفل الضاحك
مجهول الهويه لا يعرف اسمه ولم يتم التوصل
الى والديه حتى الان لكن الطاقم المستشفى
الذين يعملون جاهدين لرعايته اكدوا انه
سيبقى معهم بعد ان اسر قلوبهم بضحكاته
البريئه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
في سوريا يصعب تحديد حجم الاضرار
الاقتصاديه التي اصابت البلاد مقارنه
بالجانب التركي وذلك بسبب الاوضاع
السياسيه المنقسمه ومعاناه البلاد الحرب
المستمره منذ اكثر من 12 عاما المزيد في
التقرير التالي
خسائر متزايده في الارواح والاملاك
والاقتصاد سببه الزلزال المدمر الذي اصاب
سوريا الاسبوع الماضي ليضيف معاناه اضافيه
لاقتصاد انهكتته صراعات سياسيه لاكثر من
12 عاما وما زالت مستمره غياب البيانات
الرسميه والشفافيه واتساع رقعات تاثير
الزلزال بين مناطق خاضعه للنظام واخرى
للمعارضه يزيدان من صعوبه تقدير حجم
الاضرار والتي تجاوزت بالمجمل عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات
وحول الخسائر الماديه افادت منظمه الخوه
البيضاء بان اكثر من 300 وخمسه وسبعين
مبنى انهار كليا واكثر من 1200 مبنى انهار
جزئيا كما تصدعت الاف المباني الاخرى
كما اصاب زلزال اقتصاد سوريا في مقتل خاصه
انه ضرب اربع محافظات مسؤوله عن اكثر من
ثلث اقتصاد البلاد
فمحافظه حلب المتاثره الاكبر من الزلزال
مسؤوله عن اكثر من 16% من اقتصاد سوريا
فيما تمثل محافظه حماه المرتبه الخامسه
بنسبه مساهمه في الاقتصاد السوري بما يصل
الى تسعه في المئه ثم اللاذقيه في المرتبه
السادسه بسبعه فاصل ثمانيه في المئه
مساهمه بالاقتصاد اما محافظه ادلب التي
تنقسم السيطره فيها بين النظام والمعارضه
والمتاثره بالزلزال تصل مساهمتها في
الاقتصاد الى 2.7
انقسام الوضع السياسي في سوريا يزيد من
معاناه متاثرين بالزلزال المدمر اعاده
الاعمار على الجانب السوري خاصه في
المناطق التي تخضع للمعارضه والتي في
الاصل تضم مئات الالاف من المهجرين ستكون
الاصعب في غياب رقابه حكوميه وهرب من
المسؤوليه من المنظمات الانسانيه الدوليه
شادي الزعيم العربيه
خارجون من ركام الزلزال
انقاذ طفله من حضن اختها التي فارقت
الحياه
اخراج طفله من انقاض منزلها بعد 24 ساعه
من الزلزال
الله اكبر
رضيع ينجو من انهيار منزله
صبي يخرج حيا بعد ثلاثه ايام من الزلزال
انقاذ طفله ووالدها بعد 100 ساعه من
الزلزال
العثور على ناجيه قضت خمسه ايام تحت
الانقاض
انقاذ طفله بعد 150 ساعه من الزلزال
في ناحيه جنديرس السوريه لم يتوقع الطفل
محمد ان يجد نفسه بين ليله وضحاها بدون
ماوى ويتم الاهل بعد كارثه الزلزال المدمر
الذي راح بين ركامه والداه وشقيقاته وتبقت
له من اسرته زوجه عم والدته ياسمين مرجان
من قرخان التركيه
ما لمحوا الحزن والالم وخيبه الامل تبدو
واضحه على ملامح الطفل محمد عقيد الذي فقد
كل عائلته في جنديرس السوريه محمد لم يكن
يتوقع ان تنقلب حياته بين ليله وضحاها
ليصبح يتيما بعد ان كانت الطفل المدلله في
وسط عائلته ليجد نفسه اليوم بدون ماوى بعد
الزلزال الذي حول منزله الى حطام راح بين
ركامه والداه وشقيقاته وتبقى له من اسرته
زوجه عمي والدته ياسمين مرجان من قرخ
انا تركيا انا واطفالي هدم بنا المنزل في
جنديرس وليس لدينا اي مكان من البقاء فيه
ليس لدينا منزل اريد الخروج من المستشفى
لكن للاسف ليس لدينا مكان ياوينا اريد ان
تتم مساعده هذا الطفل
محمد بعد ان كان وحيدا لاهله اصبح وحيدا
لزوجه عمي والدته التركيه الاصل وهم
الناجيان الوحيدان من كل الاسره جراء
الزلزال المدمر في ناحيه جنديرس السوريه
بلياردم جبيلته لخاطر لم يتبقى لنا شيء لا
اريد الخروج من المستشفى حتى تتحسن صحه
ابني انا تركيا وبسوريا ليس لدينا اشخاص
نذهب عندهم اريد ان يتم تقديم المساعدات
لي
هول الصدمه لا يزال باديا عجز عن الكلام
والتعبير فالموقف لا تقوى تلك الملامح على
تحمله او حتى على الاقل تقبله
من ادلب ينضم اليها الصحفي مسلم السيد
عيسى مسلم اهلا بك معنا اليوم تنقلت بعدد
من المناطق هل يمكن ان تنقل لنا مشاهداتك
كيف هي الاوضاع في المناطق التي زرتها
وايضا معبر باب الهوى
نعم في الحقيقه يعني تنقلت في اغلب
المناطق المتضرره حتى هذه اللحظه المنطقه
الاكثر تضررا في عموم مناطق الشمال السوري
هي بلده جنديرس تليها مدينه حارم لكن
بالمقابل توقفت اغلب عمليات الدفاع المدني
لرفع الركام والبحث عن جثه المفقودين
لانها تعمل فقط في النهار وتستانف
عملياتها في اليوم التالي بحسب التوقعات
من المتوقع ان تستغرق هذه العمليات من 15
الى 20 يوم حتى تتمكن فرق الدفاع المدني
من اخلاء كل الاماكن المتضرره ورفع الركام
واستخراج ما تبقى من جثث المفقودين
وبالتالي هذه العمليه تعمل بنفس بطيء لانه
بحسب المؤشرات التي قالت ان الدفاع المدني
ومديريه الصحه انه لا وجود لمؤشرات ان
هناك احياء تحت هذه الارقام بعد انتهاء
ثمانيه ايام تقريبا
الان مسلم وضع الناجين في اليوم الثامن من
هذه الكارثه موضوع المساعدات هل بدات
تصلهم هل تكفيهم ما هي الاولويات لديهم
الان
النجين عموما تفضلوا في المراحل الاولى
البقاء في المناطق المتضرره لانتظار اي
اخبار عن ذويه لكن مع تضاؤل هذه الاخبار
بدات الاهالي ومن نجوا بالبحث عن اماكن
تؤويهم سواء في مراكز الايواء او سواء في
الاماكن الاخرى التي تعتبر اكثر امنا يعني
قبل ساعه من الان تعرضت المنطقه لهزه
ارتداديه يعني شعرنا بها حقيقه انها من
اقوى الهزات الارتداديه بعد الزلزال
الاساسي وبالتالي ليس هناك امان حتى
اللحظه الاهالي هنا تتعلق باي اعمال
لانتقال لمناطق امنه نسبيا وايضا لتعويضها
ربما بما فقدتهم من منازل وغيرها كل
الاهالي قالوا انهم لا يريدون الاقامه في
مخيمات لانهم ملوا من حركه النزوح
المتكرره هنا في الشمال السوري وهم اقل
عائله كانت قد نزحت على الاقل ثلاث او
اربع مرات من عموم مناطق سوريا واستقرت
هنا وبالتالي الاهالي لا تريد بحسب ما
قاله واكث سمعتها في الكثير من مراكز
اللواء انهم لا يريدون الاستقرار في
مخيمات او مراكز ايواء يحاولون البحث عن
حلول مستدامه
وكانت المنظمات المحليه هنا قد تلقت وعودا
ربما لكن هذه الوعود ستاخذ على الاقل 6
اشهر الى سنه حتى يتم اعاده بناء شقق
سكنيه او قرى سكنيه مخصصه للنازحين في هذه
المناطق هذه المرحله تستدعي جهود امميه
وجهود من دول العالم التي هي تعتبر صديقه
للشعب السوري ولم تتوقف عن دعمه خلال
الاثنى عشر سنه الماضيه وبالتالي تحتاج
الى مبالغ ضع منها تتحدث يعني اليوم تحدثت
مع احد المؤسسات الانسانيه قالت انها تبني
شقه سكنيه تقدمها للعائله الواحده وهي
الشقه هي 60 متر مربع فقط بكلفه تقريبا
5000 دولار وبالتالي نحتاج الى ميزانيات
ضخمه جدا حتى يتم فعلا استيعاب الكارثه
على المدى البعيد بالنسبه لمعبر باب الهوى
ماذا رصدت اليوم
كان اليوم بشكل
محسنه الوضع
يه بالدخول منذ الصباح توقفت عند مغيب
الشمس وانتهاء العمل الاداري في المعبر
لازال هناك شاحنات على الطرف التركي رصدنا
دخول تقريبا 42 شاحنه اليوم من معبر باب
الهوى توزعت بين مساعدات امميه ومساعدات
من الحكومه التركيه ولجان شعبيه تركيه
كانت قد ارسلت عبر منظمه الاهاهات هذه
المساعدات دخلت مباشره الى الطرف السوري
تم نقلها الى الشاحنات التابعه للمنظمات
المحليه ليتم توزيعها على المستفيدين في
مراكز الايواء نحن نتحدث يعني اليوم قمنا
باحصاء بسيط داخل المناطق في شمال غير
سوريا 53 مركز ايواء في هذه المناطق فقط
اقل مركز ايواء يحتوي على الف شخص
وبالتالي نتحدث عن ارقام كبيره وهناك الاف
الاسر التي لا تزال مشرده هي تسكن في بيوت
مع اقاربها او غيرها دخلت اليوم على احد
المنازل لعائله من دمشق في المنزل وهو
مكلف
مكون من غرفتين فيه عشر عوائل توزعت
العوائل الرجال في غرفه والنساء والاطفال
في غرفه وهذه الماساه لا يمكن ان تراها
الكاميرات لانها ترتكز داخل المنازل
للكثير من العوائل التي ربما تكون يعني لا
تريد البقاء في مراكز الايواء وغيرها بفضل
في هذه هل لديك اي تفاصيل عن
المساعدات التي اتت من عشائر دير الزور
هذه المساعدات هي ستاتي عبر مناطق قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه للدخول الى ارياف حلب
الشرقيه ثم وصولا بالدرجه الاولى الى
مدينه وبلده جنديرس بحسب المنظمه التي
ستعمل على توزيع هذه المساعدات من المتوقع
غدا ان تبدا عمليه التوزيع لكن انا ما
شاهدته يعني على ارض الواقع هناك تاخير
ولا اتوقع ان يتم البدء بتوزيع هذه
المساعدات قبل يومين على الاقل لان
التعقيدات هل ستصل الى ادلب ام فقط ستقتصر
على ريف حلب
بحسب المنظمه التي اشرفت وستشرف على
التوزيع قالت انها ستقتصر على ريف حلب
ببلده جنديرس
والاتارب وقريه ترمانين وبالتالي هذه
القرى ايضا هي متضرره لن تدخل الى مناطق
ادلب بسبب كما ذكرت هذه التعقيدات وطول
المسافه بين المنطقه وايضا وجود الكثير من
العراقيين شكرا لك من ادلب الصحفي مسلم
السيد عيسى